now how many on the sofa how many
sleepovers do we have rajma do sleep or
sleepwalkers sleeping am i I don't
please then Oh whoopee
I don't sleep but away I do walk now but
how are you do sleepwalk coz don't you
don't you wake up with wrappers and
things with RO oh this is awful so Jill
came up to me my wife Jill we've been
together for 28 years and she came to
the to the side of the bed she got up
before me and she said you didn't happen
to eat anything last night did you
I said no no she goes like a like a
chocolate fudge sickle says no she goes
you are you sure about that I say yes I
don't why would I do that I'm trying to
watch what I eat and she motions her
eyes to my hand which was on the bed
with as not only the stick but I had
fallen asleep before finishing it and
there was a pool of melted
children I have a wonderful transparent
relationship
talking of sleepwalking Jamie Dornan
hello
now you don't sleep eat sleep eat you
don't see Pete probably not no no but
you do sleepwalk listen I I that I'm
aware of
I've slept once in my life I was about
11 or 12 I will go I've told some
shockers on the show before I woke up
and my dad was at the end of my bed and
he said morning to me
morning you said your manling to tell me
said not really slip slip well you said
do you think you slept last night not
usually do that so I thing is them well
someone's done a poo in the bath
transoid by a sort of the process of an
elimination if my sister is working his
way do anything at home
there's
[Applause]
[Music]
you